afternoon I want to welcome you to the
2001 lecture series on business in the
environment I'm read lipsett associate
director of the industrial environmental
management program and chair of the
lecture series here the school of
Forestry and environmental studies
through this lecture series started in
nineteen ninety one we seek to bring
corporate executives and others to the
school to talk about topics of current
interests and in many cases cutting-edge
developments and environmental
management policy and Technology we
value the additional perspective that
business people bring to our discussions
at the Yale Environment school and the
opportunity to have students and faculty
meet them and for them to meet us in the
past we've explored such topics as the
emerging role of lifecycle oriented
management and product take back the
environmental impact of the service
industries and green domestic markets in
developing countries the IEM program the
sponsor of the series is a research and
teaching unit here at yells environment
school it's under its auspices is a
track within the master's program this
lecture series and the editorship of the
Journal of industrial ecology be sure to
grab some brochures on your way out the
lecture series is supported by a modest
endowment the Joel Amaro Kurahara fund
Joel was a graduate of the environment
school and the school of management in
1991 he went to work for conrail and was
very active in the global environmental
management initiative he was a very
bright very committed and very energetic
believer in the importance of greening
corporate pack practice when he died 17
years ago Conrail his colleagues family
and friends established a memorial to
honor him his parents S at the funds be
that the funds be used for this lecture
series excuse me for one minute so
this lecture series is also being
sponsored this year by Nestle Waters
division of the global firm Nestle SA
Nestle Waters is it interested in
fostering discussion around extended
producer responsibility the notion that
producers take responsibility for
products and packaging when they hit the
waste stream as part of that effort they
funded this lecture series to to get the
discussion and debate going Keep America
Beautiful a US nonprofit organization
promoting litter and waste reduction and
the resource recovery forum a uk-based
international nonprofit network
interested in sustainable waste
management are also helping and
publicizing the lecture series on EPR
our talk the talk today in our series is
by Anne Johnson program director of the
sustainable packaging coalition an
industry working group of over 200
companies from across the packaging
supply chain miss Johnson's presentation
will examine biodegradability claims and
packaging and tease out where
environmental benefits may lie
biodegradability is a notion that many
of us find intuitively compelling as a
solution to many waste issues it rate
but it raises important and complicated
questions about materials choice and
waste management for packaging and other
products ms johnson joined green blue a
non-profit Institute focused on guiding
business and industry toward sustainable
design and production in 2005 trained as
an engineer and scientist with the
background and management and
sustainability consulting she has more
than 15 years experience in materials
industrial processes environmental
management and systems evaluation of
products and packages since coming to
green blue she's directed the
sustainable packaging coalition she led
the effort to develop a consensus-based
definition of sustainable packaging for
the coalition she's been involved in a
wide variety of projects including
environmental technic
briefs on packaging materials and a
comparative package design software
application called compass she holds a
Bachelor of Arts degree from Dartmouth
College a master of science from the
University of Arizona and a master of
engineering degree in civil engineering
from the University of Virginia and I
just want to take a second to note that
she has an interesting connection to
this school for those of you that know
the the scientific history of the school
you'll know that in some ways the school
made its its first big mark in the in
the realm of research with a project
called Hubbard Brook that did a lot to
develop a notion of ecosystem ecology
her father worked very closely with Jean
lichens and her boarman who were seminal
figures in that effort and she tells me
that her father's actually buried there
so it's a very intimate connection other
speakers in this lecture series will
address the relationship between
materials choice packaging design and
waste infrastructure the findings from
the innumerable life cycle assessments
that have been done on packaging the
history of extended producer
responsibility in North America and the
history of US federal policy towards
packaging in general many of the
lectures in the series will take the
form of webinars if you'd like to be
notified of the various lectures by
email be sure to sign up at the list
just outside the lecture hall the
lecture by ms johnson is being
videotaped and may be available on the
website of the Yale School of Forestry
and environmental studies thus it is
with considerable pleasure and
anticipation that I turn the podium over
to miss Johnson who will tell us about
biodegradability and packaging finding
facts and fiction
thanks very much Reed and thank you very
much for the invitation to be here today
I have to comment that since I was in
graduate school classrooms have really
improved a lot this is really a lovely
facility anyhow as Reed said I work for
a nonprofit called green blue we're in
Charles ville Virginia we were founded
by bill McDonough and Michael Brown
guard in 2003 they have since left our
board and since that time green blue has
really expanded its sort of
philosophical approach to industrial
ecology to embrace a much broader I
think perspectives in in the sort of
cradle to cradle philosophy that they're
sometimes associated with and I came to
green blue specifically um because I was
really interested in bridging the gap
between science and business I had done
quite a bit of work and sustainability
consulting while i was at mb DC and i
could tell there was just a big
disconnect between the language of
science and the communication of
environmental issues to the business
community and how they would value and
or interpret those issues so we've got a
couple of projects on it green blue v of
clean gradients which is a sort of a
green chemistry focused project on
industrial cleaning products a year ago
we acquired a nonprofit called metaphor
on that works on forestry issues they do
a lot of work in the forest products as
well as printed paper industry and then
the sustainable packaging coalition
which is the project that I manage so to
get to the spc it was founded in 2004 by
seven companies who we sort of went out
with the with an idea is their interest
in exploring what the idea of
sustainability means in the context of
packaging and we had a meeting with
about 30 companies and seven of them
stepped up and said yeah this is really
interesting this is a very pertinent
business issue for us it's on all of our
corporate agendas and we feel very
deeply that
you need to figure out what can we do to
improve packaging we think design is a
really important leverage point for
doing that so that was really the
inspiration for getting the group
together and since then we've grown to
over 220 member companies from across
the value chain so we have many many
commodity raw materials suppliers we
have a lot of what we call packaging
converters people who take materials
convert them into packaging format we
have a significant number of brand
owners or retailers who are the folks
who typically specify packaging but we
also have a lot of designers marketing
people recyclers and technology
companies in our membership but it's a
very unique organization in that we do
have this whole value chain of packaging
represented our real mission has been to
put out a vision of what sustainability
for packaging needs and then build the
tools the resources the knowledge base
for companies to then go act on that
vision so that's what we've been doing
for the last six years so I wanted to
start with this picture to just try to
put the role of biodegradation in sort
of context of when we think about what
we do to materials to make them valuable
for packaging so if we look at sort of
virgin materials where we're extracting
materials either from the biosphere or
we're taking raw materials we're
investing money effort environmental
impact in making them more valuable as
we go up the value chain and that's why
we want to try to keep things up here as
much as we can so we we use we recycle
we can chemically recycle when we think
about composting that's a that's a
strategy that's coming up for packaging
there's a lot of interest in that we
have a pretty significant loss of value
in materials when we compost so it's
maybe not always our highest best use of
materials necessarily but it's a really
important waste
management strategy that currently we
don't really have much infrastructure
for so I just sort of put this up there
for some context of where maybe
composting is when we think about other
recovery scenarios so I wanted to give
you some background of what's driving
interest in in biodegradable packaging
why is it such a hot topic there is a
huge amount of misunderstanding around
this idea in the marketplace and perhaps
the most confused or consumers so I
wanted to show you this is sort of a a
chart that we use a lot we called it our
flayed donut and it just shows you know
again how resources come into the value
chain how they're converted and where
they go and this is the relationship I'm
going to talk to you about because
retailers are a very very important link
between how we make materials and how
they're communicated to consumers they
live on this edge between those two
people retailers seldom have packaging
departments even though they may have
big private label portions of their
companies they rarely employ the
engineers and designers for their
packaging they contracted out on the
other hand brand owners your Unilever's
your pngs your cokes in your Pepsi's
they often have very sophisticated
packaging divisions as well as life
cycle assessment folks these people spec
packaging and they communicate to
consumers about packaging but they're
not necessarily the most informed
audience for that conversation so we're
materials are made is way back here
there's a lot of stuff that happens
along here additive suppliers for
polymers life somewhere out here they
you know they're they're coming into
your commodity producers so I just want
you to have a sense of what the dynamic
of the marketplace is for packaging so
this is a picture that I'm sure all of
you have deeply ingrained in your mind
is people familiar with industrial
ecology but I think there's a very
intrinsic connection to the
for a lot of people when you communicate
to consumers about using nature as a
model for materials it's very intuitive
it's um I have a third grader who's now
studying the you know the life cycle of
a butterfly and wrong way and she really
gets this little kids get this when
we're in kindergarten we start teaching
this and as we get to the older what we
understand is the way this works is we
have these complex you know processes in
decomposition and biodegradation that
allows us to occur we think of this is a
very beneficent type of system we live
in this system it's our biosphere we use
it as an analogy to talk about how we
can make our industrial practice more
sustainable but that has some
interesting consequences when we talk
about consumers so when we think about
the trends that are influencing
packaging despite a lot of effort to
improve packaging over the years and we
can sort of track this in developed
economies we can see that the amount of
packaging waste produced per capita
actually d links at a certain level that
they are in fact doing a pretty good job
at designing packaging to be more
resource-efficient to be lighter because
typically we see packaging directly
associated with economic growth but
despite those efforts in any economy on
the planet consumers associate packaging
with waste and they they also associated
with environmental impact so there's a
subtext underneath there which we know
that most products probably have far
more environmental impact than the
package itself but to consumers that's
very opaque to them they drink the water
they're left with this in their hand
they got to figure out what to do with
it it's waste so packaging on is on the
agenda of pretty much any big branded
company and what you see is that a lot
of these companies are taking positions
targets around renewable materials I
think in some cases these targets have
been made without perhaps a lot of study
or thinking about what the consequence
of that is but you do have a general
sort of corporate trend towards a
position a positive position around
renewable materials at the same time
there's a lot of pressure to be more
resource-efficient the walmarts
packaging scorecard has been a really
significant driver in this marketplace
and their measure for packaging has been
weight based so the lighter your package
the better it's going to score the
result of that but also I think in your
general types of source reduction
strategies is you're moving to lighter
materials what are lighter materials
they're polymers what are those polymer
types their films so we're moving from
heavier rigid types of formats of
packaging into flexible packaging so
anybody goes to the granola aisle it
used to come in the box you know a bag
in a box and now it comes in a multi
laminate ziplock bag that's a trend
that's happening across consumer
products and you see that in food you
see it in personal care we see it pretty
much everywhere the side effect of that
is these materials are not typically
recyclable so you have this dichotomy in
companies packaging the scene is waste
the resources efficient solution that
you're driving towards is a non
recyclable type of material therefore
they're looking for solutions to that
and biodegradable materials seems like a
solution to that problem so what a
consumers think about biodegradability
um in 2006 the American Chemistry
Council did an interesting survey
looking at looking at UM consumer
additives sorry consumer attitudes
around biodegradable and i found this
fascinating and this gets back to my
earlier comment about i think the the
very intrinsic connection to nature as a
model for materials so consumers think
that
a degradable means that the material can
break down in its own on that it happens
pretty quickly in a year or less and
that it disappears so clearly
thermodynamics is not a strong part of
most consumers mind set on but they also
have kind of a perverse connection to
this in terms of their personal behavior
so on Keep America Beautiful thankfully
did another consider study in 2008 to
follow their previous study which
occurred in 1969 so they waited a while
and what they found is that the thing we
litter most or cigarettes in any
environment cigarette butts or what you
find by far and away which I found
amazing but they found that
biodegradability is actually a
characteristic that leads to more
littering behavior if people think
something is biodegradable like an apple
or whatever you can toss it so that was
an interesting fact to me but you can
also see in their study was only
terrestrial litter that packaging is a
big part of what we find in litter now
they had a very interesting you know to
show the change in the the types of
materials you find in litter and it used
to be glass and cans and now it has and
paper now you see very little almost no
glass very few cans and you see a lot of
people inside the road if there are cans
picking them up but you see plastic and
films and fast food wrappers so we're
just going to quickly go over the types
of materials we're talking about where
when we talk about bio degradable
packaging and there's some interesting
sort of ironies in this on so here are
obvious ones that we think about you
know we have our corrugated or box board
are molded pulp all tree-based fibers
all of which are biodegradable but I'm
not certain I've ever actually seen a
biodegradable claim on these materials
for the most part usually it's some sort
of recyclable label we can make them non
biodegradable by co
them with polymers um we have other
biomes too far sorry we have other
bio-based packaging materials that we're
seeing more frequently which are
non-traditional fibers so you'll see
them in a lot of molded on formats there
they can be bagasse palm fiber straw can
I have and then we see extruded or foam
starches and it could be either potato
or corn starches again these are all
very readily biodegradable types of
materials and we would also probably
consider these home compostable in many
situations but we have a new class of
biodegradable materials that are more
complex consumers don't know much about
them and in some cases I don't think
businesses know much about them either
um so we saw in the 1990s in particular
the introduction of a lot of starch
based polymers and I have a couple of
them these are actually trade names
these are very readily biodegradable
polymers in the last decade we've seen
the introduction of some biopolymers
based on corn and PHA which can actually
come from a couple of different sources
right now the the commercial approach
has been through fermentation but they
are compostable bio-based polymers there
is this is the commercially the most
prominent one you see it in some rigid
packaging you see it in some films and
you see it in coatings PHA is just on
the sort of the edge of being
commercialized and I think I think it's
a DM and metabolic SAR we're working on
a joint venture with that I'm not
certain where that stands and then you
have traditional cellulosic types of
materials that are out there that have
been out there for a long time but we're
actually seeing some
interesting innovation around though
there the class that I think is very
complicated is this fossil fuel-based
class of biodegradable polymers and I
should caveat that by saying degradable
polymers are not actually biodegradable
they physically degrade and we saw those
i think in 80s and early 90s we had a
lot of degradable trash bags and other
additive ated polymers that we realized
that that ended up being a real problem
that because they don't go away you just
go from visible litter to microscopic
litter however these are actually
regulated all those beverage six-pack
holders that are plastic have to be
degradable polymers and that's for that
was based on wildlife protection in
aquatic environments but the important
thing to take away is they're not
actually biodegradable so we have two
classes of polymers oxxo biodegradable
and omni degradable where we see a lot
of a lot of marketing push towards those
a lot of interest on the part of
business and I think a lot of confusion
on the part of consumers I want I put
this slide up there because we also have
bio-based but not biodegradable or
compostable polymers now so we have
traditional polymers that are being made
with fossil fuel I'm sorry with
bio-based feedstocks and we have both
polyethylenes and polyethylene
terephthalate now and the big there's
been a lot of push around this coke
plant bottle which is thirty percent
plant-based so they're using sugar cane
making ethanol and then they're making
some of the feedstocks for the p ET out
of it now the problem is some people see
this and say well why if it's bio-based
why isn't it biodegradable so it's
interesting because when we first
started making polymers they were
bio-based we used to make polymers out
of sugar cane so it's important that
these are out there but they shouldn't
be confused with
bio-based polymers that are also
biodegradable so just to go into some of
the a quick you know breakdown on how
these technologies actually work ox
those are are a very diverse class of
polymer additives they're usually
compounded into a material at about one
to three percent and it's all they're
almost all they're always putting fossil
fuel-based polymers and they tend to be
metal steroids traditionally they had
been cobalt-based but increasingly as
concerns over cobalt went up the
industry has innovated around other
types of metals and manganese magnesium
iron zinc are our common ones that you
see now so they work in two ways through
the action of heat or light they oxidize
some of the polymer bonds so they make
the polymer chains shorter and therefore
theoretically more accessible to
microbes so the second step then is that
once that decision happened those
polymer chains then can become food for
microbes however oxxo biodegradable
polymers do not meet any composed
ability standards today so this becomes
this very sort of complex interaction
between you know a material and then how
do we judge the characteristic of its
biodegradability on they have been on
the market for some time in Europe they
were quite prevalent a decade ago and
there's been a there were quite a few of
these additive producers I think they're
often marketed as a solution to litter
but we've had problems with some
misleading claims around them about that
they biodegrade in landfills however
there's not a lot of heat or light in
landfills necessarily so obviously that
takes some more study
I got an email about six months ago that
goes and what the hell is an omni
degradable wrote back and I said I don't
know I don't know very much about them
but this is what I do know it is an
organic additive added to fossil
fuel-based polymers um it can be based
on EV a or p voh so these are organic
based materials I looked up an msds for
one of these additives yesterday and it
said miscellany miscellaneous
organoleptic chemicals so i'm actually
not certain what that means and that's
part of the problem is that we don't
really know what the chemistry of these
materials of these additives are and
when you ask you typically don't get the
information so I think there's a lot of
there's not a lot of clarity on really
what is the chemistry of these additives
however we're seeing them used in a lot
of common polymers that we use in
packaging namely polyethylene and p ET
and that gets people in the recycling
side of packaging concerned and there
was concern about that in terms of oxes
too because you don't want materials in
your recycling stream to start breaking
down on you so as far as I know none of
the Omni degradable materials meet
composed ability standards to date on
and I'm going to go over this little
later but they were also 11 on material
from a producer was recently the subject
of an of a national advertising and
review ruling about making a misleading
claim around biodegrading in a landfill
and nine to six months I'm sorry I did
that wrong it should be six to nine
months
so a couple of quick definitions this is
from the European Standard call me an 13
for 32 it is a compostable ities
standard ad that's part of that's used
within the cen standards under the
packaging waste directive in Europe it's
a very clear standard on its I like it
because I think it's very thorough it's
very clear and they have this nice
statement about ultimate
biodegradability all of you know what
biodegradability is I'm sure but it's my
they're very clear to point out that
ultimate biodegradability has a context
in Arabic environments and it has a
context in anaerobic environments and
that's very pertinent for packaging so
to go through the standard just in a
very high level it says a compostable
packaging material has to meet a couple
of tests it needs to need a test around
biodegradability around disintegration
composed compost quality and
recognizability so the biodegradability
they actually have a a test for both
aerobic and anaerobic but what they're
saying is in a composting system an
aerobic composting system you should be
able to prove that ninety percent of
that material degrades within six months
so they've given it a percentage of
degradation we measure it through
evolution of co2 and a timeframe which
is very very important disintegration
means that even if you see a lot of CEO
to I gotta look at it and those bits
have to be small I can't have big chunks
of polymer left in my compost pile even
if you say there you know the co2 should
prove that it's gone quality means that
if you're using inks or additives or
other things that might potentially
contaminate that compost and compromise
the viability of stuff that would grow
in it that's not going to work and
recognizability is a very interesting
aspect which is the material needs to be
labeled clearly labeled as compostable
so that's kind of a recognition that
consumers and other people need to be
able to tell this is a compostable
material these are some relevant
standards in the u.s. we use ASTM 6404
compostable plastics in ASTM 6868 for
biodegradable paper products that have a
plastic coating and again the thing i
want to note in here is these are
limited to municipal and industrial
aerobic composting facility so this is
not your backyard heat this is a managed
system that has temperature conditions
that you would not find in a home
compost situation that's a very
important caveat because until I've got
in this business I actually do know that
I've sort of thought all composting
systems were the same but this is very
clearly an engineered system we turn the
piles so on and so forth so this is
probably an example of compostable
packaging that you might all be familiar
with this year so frito-lay spent a lot
of money on investing in the research
and development to create a compostable
film for their chip bag chip bags sit on
a shelf for no more than 60 days on at
which point they're pulled and if they
haven't been sold there's obviously
potato chips in them and boy wouldn't be
nice to be able to just compile and you
know compost the whole the whole bit so
you can either put a 60 day chip and a
thousand-year bag or you could put a 60
day chip in a compostable bag so I think
they went into this knowing that
basically there is not a lot of
municipal collection of compostable
materials you have some communities in
Francisco among them who collect
compostable materials but most
communities don't and I live in central
Virginia and it's definitely if you
don't so there's little collection
there's very little composting
infrastructure most of what we have for
composting infrastructure is for green
waste so it's for yard trimmings and
ask clippings and those guys don't want
packaging the fate of compostable
materials in landfills is no different
the conditions and landfills are such
that this bag is likely not going to
degrade so you want you asked why would
a company do it and they're doing it
because it's an investment for the
future and it's really looking at how
anticipating a future infrastructure how
might we fit into that because they're
not really in the business of selling
packaging they're in the business of
selling food and we'll look at how
important food waste is in a second so
I'm going to shift gears now to sort of
the realm of claims and how we talk
about biodegradability to on consumers
so I threw the whole thing in here from
the green guide so the Federal Trade
Commission has a has a guidance document
called the green guides for companies
who are going to communicate about their
products to businesses and consumers and
it says that you the way they divided up
is you can make an unqualified claim and
if you're going to make an unqualified
claim about biodegradability you have to
be able to somehow prove that it
decomposes into elements found in nature
within a reasonably short period of time
after customary disposal well reasonably
short time is very lawyerly way right
that leaves a huge door open what is
reasonably short they have subsequently
after three years of review they have
refined that short period of time at
least for landfills to be one year if
you're going to make a qualified claim
which is the other type of claim you can
make you have to talk about the ability
to grade an environment where it's
customarily disposed and the rate and
extent of degradation so those are the
sort of tests that companies have to
have to go after to make a valid claim
however you'll notice I mean it doesn't
typically reference any particular
specification or test method so just to
show some examples of what this looks
like on packaging this is a compostable
bag made out of a corn starch based
polymer it has I mean they've left
nothing undone here they have the BPI
compostable label they have the din
circo compostable labour label so this
is us this is I think this is German and
then this is a Belgian I think VIN code
is a Belgian compostable ax t so that is
labeled with every composed ability
label I'm aware of so and then they have
this green stripe here the green cart
means it goes in your composting cart
that is pretty clearly meets the
recognizability aspect of that Ian
standard this is um something that I got
in the mail and they're telling me that
this bag is ldpe they're saying that a
biodegrades in that's where I got it
from does not say nine to 60 months okay
so it's nine months so no no nine months
to five years in the presence of
microorganisms it's also recyclable I
mean this is great stuff this does
everything for me right here so that's
an example of a qualified claim right
there so this is where it gets complex
is that all of you know that the problem
with bio degradation is that the
conditions really matter what's the
temperature what's the moisture what's
the oxygen conditions and are there any
critters there who are actually fine
mist of food so any one of those things
can change the rate on in the
thoroughness of biodegradation alright
so let's get into the fiction part of my
presentation here
so this is where I think you see the
tension between the desire to market to
that intrinsic belief that
biodegradability is a beneficial
characteristic and I think the science
behind the environmental benefit so this
is a product and I just want to be clear
these are some slides that I used from a
friend of mine oops sorry Steve mojo
he's the executive director of the
biodegradable products Institute this is
a PE t bottle that we would normally
recycle but it has an omni degradable
additive in it so they're also saying
it's biodegradable and I think they stay
up here on it's not a not so it's not
pla on you can't see it but it's back
here it it's a plastic container that
biodegrades and anaerobic or aerobic
environments so it's got you covered no
matter what and on their website they
showed their test data to substantiate
their claim and I actually really like
this word here apparently so they did a
15 day test which i think I'm trying to
remember I'm not entirely certain it's
an anaerobic test that they did because
they wanted to prove that it biodegraded
degrades in a landfill and I'm trying to
remember the number of days that you
have to test that form not quite certain
but so they looked at their line and
they they just extrapolated it out so
that was their control that would be
cellulose and then that's theirs while
the biodegradable products Institute
also ran a test using the same test
method and the test method is ASTM d
5511 this is a test method for bio
degradation in the presence of a highly
reactive environment which in this case
is sewage sludge
probably not very indicative on the
environment that one finds in a landfill
and very interestingly so here's the
control here's polyethylene that does
nothing there's there cellulose mind the
blue line right there and then this was
their test line and here's 60 days and I
think this is 30 days so they ran the
test twice as long and that's a pretty
pretty flat rate so the lesson here is
that when the national advertising
division reviewed this because somebody
took it to them as a mediator and said
we believe this is a misleading claim
this was the ruling on December 12th or
14th of last year that this is a body
that outside of going to court will make
rulings on in consumer claims so they
they cite the FTC here and I think you
can read that for yourself they're
saying that ASTM D 5511 just doesn't
represent what we find in a landfill
it's very inappropriate to apply it and
base a claim on it so this is a problem
and we would recommend you not make this
type of claim so the big thing is
anaerobic digesters you know that was
the purpose of 5511 it was too it was to
model an anaerobic digester not a
landfill so this is just a summary of
some any D cases that have come up
around oxxo biodegradable and omni
degradable 'he's and you can see that
over the last several years there have
been a lot of these claims that have
been found problematic and the claims
are either around that there are also
biodegradable biodegradable or
biodegradable in landfills so there's
been a pattern here that I think has led
to a lot of confusion in the marketplace
in
has made it difficult for legitimate
producers and biodegradable materials to
be able to communicate about the
attributes in their of their materials
so it leads you to this question so fire
derivation even happens what is the
environmental benefit so I just want to
quickly show you this is what we throw
away every year this is the sort of
characterization of us municipal solid
waste over sixty percent of it is
organic materials so we have yard
trimmings we have food scraps we have
paid for a paperboard we have wood
there's a lot of organic stuff that we
throw into a landfill the way we manage
it is we landfill more than half of it
so to the FTC's point of the likely
disposal environment you're likely to
end up in a landfill and and especially
if you're not a recyclable material this
composted piece of our management is
almost all green waste it's all grass
clippings leaves and things like that so
read you know landfills far better than
I do but / EPA regulation on landfills
after what 1970 or something we're
really engineered to be dry tunes
they're engineered to not let the water
out the bottom and once you cap them if
they're engineered to not let the water
at the top we're seeing a trend towards
bioreactors but there are very very few
of them in bioreactors you recirculate
the the leachate to encourage
degradation but when you cut through a
landfill and look at them they're very
heterogeneous I mean we throw all our
stuff in a plastic bag the plastic bag
gets thrown on a hole we put other stuff
around and we compact at we put dirt on
it the the it's a very inconsistent
environment and because of that the the
conditions to the exposure to water to
oxygen to microbes is really really
variable its food is pre colonized with
microbes it can help with degradation
packaging is not and in fact we know
that a lot of packaging is food
specification we don't want microbes on
your on your packaging so packaging
actually often doesn't have some of the
conditions that would would lead to
degradation so this is out of the EPA's
on greenhouse gas emission inventory and
in 1990 landfills were the largest
anthropogenic source of greenhouse gases
in the United States so that leads you
to think well why would I want
biodegradation to occur whether it
occurred aerobic Lee in the landfill but
we also know it's an oxygen-deprived
system so I'm likely to evolve methane
which is going to be 25 times more
greenhouse gas effective than co2 we
look more recently I'm off the chart
here and it's gone down a little bit but
now landfills are the second most
significant source of the anthropogenic
greenhouse gas emissions so there is
there is a conflict between I think this
interest in biodegradable packaging and
the reality of what the likely
disposable disposal environment is and
on the you know the context of what's
going to happen with a package in the
landfill so I'm not going to belabor
this slide on but there's this
interesting fact that things with a lot
of lignin in them do not decompose
readily in anaerobic environment so
things like leads would um don't really
um decompose well under landfill
conditions that are oxygen limited and
this is sort of a summary of how EPA
sort of characterizes that and what you
see is that food actually decomposes
relatively rapidly in landfills and
things like newspaper or leads don't
so not very intuitive I mean you think
of those as organic materials while we
would think they would go away but
because of lignin and they actually
don't so this is what the mix of wastes
in landfills look like over the last 20
years and you can see we've made some
concerted effort to drop you know to
divert organic waste from landfills and
this is what goes to landfill so before
I showed you what we generate this is
now what goes to landfills but what's
interesting is looking at how that
composition within what goes to landfill
and his organic has changed and you can
see that we've actually been diverting a
fair amount of paper and paperboard and
in fact corrugated is one of the most
highly recycled materials we have but
what we see is that food has actually
gone up in that 20-year period Reid and
I were talking about this this morning
at things because we all go out to eat
all the time I don't know no scientific
basis for that we also know that we've
been doing a pretty good job at
diverting green waste from landfills but
despite those efforts the amount of
methane generated has actually gone up
in in co2 equivalents but what has
controlled it overall is that our
management strategies have dramatically
changed over that 20 years so we slowly
but surely are doing more waste energy
we are flaring a ton so that means we
have managed landfills for piping and
more flaring them this is soil oxidation
and then this is what we're actually
emitting so you can see that that what
were we're actually emitting has gone
down a bit but since there's been so
much growth in the overall emissions the
management strategies have actually
helped not make that as big a change as
it could have been so just as a summary
I think that you know when we look at
the characteristic of biodegradability
in the context of packaging it's a very
complex story I think there is this in
just intrinsic belief by consumers the
biodegradation is a benefit because it's
natural it's benign therefore it must be
good for the environment right but we're
just lacking that broader sort of
systemic context of where is it going
and what happens to it when it gets
there so without that context you can't
really assess whether you know
biodegradation is a is a benefit or not
since most packaging still goes to
landfills clearly it's a problem we've
got to look at it in that context so
when I spoke to the FTC and they had a
hearing two years ago or three years ago
for the revision of green guides we one
of my recommendations is that
biodegradable should be stricken as a
consumer claim because there's just too
much complexity underneath it for
consumers to understand it in the
context of packaging so that's it for me
Steve I'm with a PC recycling and I
recycle my company recycles millions of
pounds per month plastic and do you
think that the manufacturers and the
brand producers are pushing
biodegradable as a claim for market
share because it's it feels to the
soccer moms they look at it and say hey
it's great and sorry my second part of
the question would be what happens when
degradable plastic mixes in with my non
degradable plastic and I sell it to a
plastic lumber manufacturer and it gets
exposed to oxygen in sunlight and the
deck start falling in that they may
sharks long crowded right well to your
second question they're going to be
bummed right I mean there's just no
doubt the first question is I think that
I would like to be generous and say that
brand owners are not doing that for
market share I would certainly say that
I think your large brand owners with
deep pockets that have big legal
departments are definitely not doing
that I think you probably have niche
products where they may be doing Matt
thinking it's something that's very
consistent with their product line but
they don't really have the in-house
expertise to know otherwise because I
think in many cases businesses are
simply as misinformed as consumers on
some of this complexity I'm sure you're
familiar with a PRS position on oxy owes
that they present a huge concern to the
recycling community because when do you
know that oxidation has started and
where is it in its lifespan when you get
it as a recycler so i think it's a it's
a serious problem but it's you know it's
it's the trend in polymers as we just
keep diversifying making more
combinations and permutations of me it's
the thing we love about polymers and
it's the thing that makes them so
difficult
Harold's day these like the sunchips bag
is that used for feedstock what do you
mean by feedstock the bag itself order
I'm saying that the strategy is a
feedstock substitution so that bag used
to be made out of oriented polypropylene
so that's made from you know fossil
fuels so they are replacing it with a
feedstock that's now made from a
biogenic source of carbon so from corn
and obviously as a frito-lay company
they sell a lot of corn so you know
there is some consistency with with that
strategy with their their product so the
benefit but the the carbon benefit is in
the feedstock substitution for
non-renewable fossil fuel based material
for a biogenic current carbon you know
feedstock hi my name is Justin Linden
maram at the school management given the
lack of infrastructure for composting do
you think that the companies that are
making biodegradable even true
biodegradable plastics are doing more
harm than good given that the vast
majority is not being composted no
because I think those materials have
their fate in a landfill is no different
they don't if they end up in a landfill
there I don't think they're going to be
any more harmful to the environment but
I think the question comes down to how
do you ever do anything different than
what we're doing now if we don't have
anything that leads us to you something
different we're just stuck you know
we're just going to keep throwing stuff
in a hole in the ground and you the
opportunity for composting is not
packaging you saw that in the the mix of
what goes to landfill its food and food
is the stuff that actually biodegrades
in a landfill it's the stuff we got to
get out of landfill so packaging could
be a medium for getting food out of the
landfill ultimately so I think that we
have to make sure that we look at what
is the priority and that that we know
that a lot of packaging that's going
to landfills is not degrading because it
has high lignan we know stuff that is
compostable even because of the
conditions of the landfill is not likely
to biodegrade so it's probably Nets out
you know not not any worse for wear but
what it does is it opens the door to a
new end of life scenario where we could
actually do something that would be more
beneficial than a landfill which is to
compost it and it would be a lot more
beneficial if we could if that
facilitated food if all of us eating in
restaurants is wasting so much food and
throwing it you know in landfills
there's a big opportunity to to change
the equation with respect to carbon
hi Alicia is missing with the school of
management in the school of forestry so
it seems like the missing link in all of
this is more industrial composting
facility as more municipal industrial
composters is there has there been any
effort on the part of the packaging
industry to advocate to partner with you
Nissa pallet ease to partner with the
types of companies that construct those
types of facilities or but the
government there there is there was just
a big us composting council meeting a
week or two ago that i didn't go to but
this is a red hot topic in the industry
i think there's a lot of interest i
would say maybe not so much particularly
from the material producers are very
obviously if you're making a compostable
material you want to make sure that
there is an infrastructure at the other
end to receive it but when you think
about it when we introduce this bottle
was there any expectation that there
were the infrastructure for it no the me
know the producers were not held
responsible for ensuring that this thing
had a positive you know life cycle
through its whole life it came after the
fact the equation has definitely changed
down you put a material out in the
market you better have a good end of
life solutions so there's been a lot of
effort in fact I think nature works the
one site that we have that actually
tells you where composting facilities
are in the u.s. I think nature works
compiled that database originally and I
think bio cycle may maintain that but
there are issues composting requires
permitting most calm posters or
independent operators like recyclers and
municipalities sell them compost in some
cases they do but municipalities don't
have any money I mean they don't have
any money to support recycling programs
they're not going to have any money to
start a composting so this is going to
be a business you know that it has to
start and what we see already is that
there is a mismatch between some of the
compostable ities standards and
operating conditions of what we see in
composting facilities so to make money
and composting my turn rate might be 45
days or 60
days not a hundred and eighty days which
is the time frame and many standards so
we need to close the gap between making
sure that we have standards that
accurately reflect the way people
operate as well as to figure out you
know what are going to end markets for
that compost and is permitting going to
be a barrier or you know something that
helps support it but you know some of
these facilities you know you can have
other problems and pest problems and
especially if you have food that's
that's a particular challenge but it's
one that certainly that shouldn't slow
us down I mean if we can crash-land
something on Mars we should be able to
figure out food composting
hi towards the beginning of your talk
you mentioned that there's a movement
towards minimizing packaging when I
didn't have thinner materials an
introduction of biodegradable plastics
but there's also new products out there
like the sugar I by for instance now
came out in a resealable bag that's
recyclable and I didn't know if you can
speak to this movement as opposed to
biodegradable products and also the
TerraCycle program I didn't know if you
knew anything about that yeah well we
can recycle that sugar bag but it's a
it's a flexible film and a lot of a lot
of communities don't accept it so it's
not collected at very high rates at all
and that's the same way you know ldpe
carrier bags are very recyclable and
most retail stores will have been where
you can put it in there those are
commonly feedstocks for plastic lumber
or four trucks and they like that it can
be recycled into that the reality is
those types of packages are rarely
collected and they're not recycled at a
very very high rate I think the plastics
industry is working very very hard on
that to do that but to get some of the
characteristics that we like inflexible
packages it means that they're very
heterogeneous when you collect them that
makes it hard for a recycler to predict
what are the properties of this stuff
when it comes out the end and you need
to know what the properties are if
you're going to make a product you can't
happen this is this gentleman's point
that if I have something in here that
might you know start to degrade you know
I'm going to have a problem with my my
customer on TerraCycle I don't know if
you've seen their recent I think there
are only so many recycled backpacks and
handbags and other things we can have in
the world right and I think that you
know there is really outstanding in
tent behind there but i think the
practicality of how the types of volumes
that we need to push through to really
effectively recycle plastics is not
going to happen through that kind of
program and in fact i think they've said
that they use a huge amount of
post-industrial scrap they're not using
pre consumed post-consumer so you know
there's a challenge on that on that
front and certainly reuse is something
that we used to do a lot of reuse but we
found out that washing when you have to
heat water takes a lot of energy and so
we we moved out of a lot of reusable
glass containers they actually have a
really interesting reuse model in Canada
they have a common footprint beer bottle
the beer industry collects all their
bottles they wash them and they reuse
them and they just put their own label
on to identify them that makes a lot of
sense in Canada where you have a lot of
water and a lot of hydroelectric but in
Arizona that model is probably not going
to work very well so we did used to do
that but I think from an energy
perspective you would find especially in
the u.s. coal-burning power plants that
the energy it takes to heat the water to
wash the bottle it's it's not from an
environmental perspective that may not
be the best strategy I'm not saying it
isn't but I'm saying I think that's a
likely scenario and and you've seen
companies that have moved out of that
there are new clean cleaning systems
that are I think there's some type of
nitrogen flush system that actually
don't use water and I think you've seen
in Europe summary use systems that are
that are moving in that direction but I
don't know that much about that
technology
question I was wondering if you could
speak a little bit to the relationship
between biodegradability and litter well
I don't know that much about that
because we actually don't know very much
about litter because our data is really
poor so obviously those things that are
persistent in the environment are the
things that are bigger litter issues and
marine debris is if you know I've heard
you had a recent speaker on that I mean
it is a it is a hot topic and the
plastics industry is certainly paying
attention to it I think that you know
when you look at the trajectory plastics
are positioned as a very resource
efficient material and we know that
we're using more and more of it there's
more more of it in our waste streams and
I think as you look forward in time and
you look at where we're going to be
selling products in the future it's in
our emerging markets which tend to have
very underdeveloped waste management
systems and in those environments if
you're not managing waste if it's not
managed that's probably the worst
outcome for materials that are
persistent in the environment and we see
that I mean when you go to parts of the
world where we don't have good waste
management you see incredible litter
problems so i think that's that's going
to be a tough nut to crack
oh I got a green yell hat thank you very
much that's great
you